Have you ever wondered how your dog experiences the world?
Here's what she sees.
Not terribly interesting.
But what she smells, that's a totally different story.
And it begins at her wonderfully developed nose.
As your dog catches the first hints of fresh air,...
...her nose's moist, spongy outside helps capture any scents the breeze carries.
The ability to smell separately with each nostril, smelling in stereo,...
...helps to determine the direction of the smell's source...
...so that within the first few moments of sniffing,...
...the dog starts to become aware of not just what kinds of things are out there...
...but also where they're located.